how are you doing
today sir i am doing very well steve for
you well
i'm doing listen as well as i can be um
like i said to you before the interview
started i'm a big fan of your work
uh i have a lot of questions for you but
i want to ask you at least
one or two things you've not been asked
today
so the first thing is uh what tv series
would you love to guest
write and direct you mean that's on now
or of all time well i kind of want to
know what's on now
but then i guess also all time
i mean i would have loved to have done
some of the wire
for sure um
that would have been fantastic um
[Music]
i mean i loved queen's gambit i have to
be honest and say i thought that was
absolutely brilliant
uh i mean do you want me to carry on and
on there's two
no i have so many other questions um if
you
if you could get the financing together
right now
for any project what would you make and
why
well i mean
it's not the financing i've i've i've
long wanted to do a version of 1984.
uh but the issue is
not really the financing it's partly the
right situation which is quite
complicated
and also finding a way to tell that
story in a way it's just
so relevant to today you know that novel
that the hard thing to do is to not make
it sink under the weight of its own
relevance if you can see
it's a counter-intuitive problem with
with an adaptation in 1984
but but but i think there is some i mean
that's what's one of my
favorite books uh so
you know it's an indictment of tyranny
and a warning from history but but i
think that an
adaptation for today would be extremely
timely if
if i could ever find a way to do it i
think one of the interesting things
about something like that is
that with the um with streaming
maybe the the fact that it doesn't have
to be a two-hour movie
the fact that you could maybe tell that
over four or six hours like queen's
gambit
uh maybe that opens the door a little
bit more
maybe i think there's another problem
with with what i'd say those kind of ur
texts is that they've been so
uh ripped off over the years
and mined by other you know in other
ways
the the the the sort of classic er text
of that piece which 94 is of
that it gets very hard to serve it up in
a way that doesn't
feel like you've seen it before in a
funny way
um uh so that's certainly a problem
but you know it's it's i think
that someone's gonna do it
someone is gonna do it that's for sure
completely
i'll be the first to shake hands with
the person who gets there if they do it
before i do
uh jumping into why i get to talk to you
today i want to say for everyone
watching you did a fantastic job
you and tom together are what we call um
real good
oh that's nice well thank you uh i'm
i'm always fascinated by the editing
process because it's the final rewrite
uh speaking to tom earlier he said there
were some scenes that didn't make the
finished cut
um how long for example on something
like this uh how long was your first cut
versus the finished film
i think i can't remember exactly i think
we probably took
30 minutes out something like that um
[Music]
there were a few things that that we
took out for sure
um sometimes you
find when you shoot a movie that you've
got that scene already
that actually has seen that you thought
was very different turns out
to be the same as something you've
already got
uh i mean it's a it's a mysterious and
wondrous process
editing because it's the moment when
your film starts to take
shape and i was very lucky to have billy
goldberg obviously the great billy
gomberg
this is our second film together and
he does such a beautiful job of finding
the film
that you most dreamt of when you started
you know
and i can't pay him a higher tribute
than that because
it takes but first of all it takes great
storytelling gifts
on the path of the editor and great
taste and judgment
and beautiful obviously technical
ability but
ultimately you have to have a
sensitivity to what the intent of the
filmmaker is because you're
you're roped together you know on on the
mountain
face climbing it together it's the
journey only you and your editor can
take ultimately
towards what the finished piece is
and and it's
it's a relationship that has to be
based on mutual
mutual shared sense of where the story
ultimately lies
and a willingness to be clear-eyed about
what you've actually got
what you don't actually have why you
didn't get
things that you thought were important
and maybe they aren't important
and how you can most
put to best effect things that were
important that you do have if that makes
sense
and it's a it's a beautiful
uh relationship of music making
cutting a film together you know and uh
and i'm always struck by
the way every film for a filmmaker
is a descent into the despair
of your first assembly and then a hand
over hand
ascent to the summit of
at least something you hope will be
possible
and sometimes when you've got a great
editor it's better than that
i've spoken to a lot of filmmakers um
that talk about how
after watching their first cut uh that
all they're thinking about is why did i
decide to become a filmmaker because i
am [ __ ] terrible at it
i'm finished i'll never work again
what did i ever think i was doing on
this film
oh my god this is going to be
unreleasable i mean all those things
always go through your mind there are
certain truths about filmmaking
rushes are always genius
always want to make you slit your throat
and the finished film when you get there
is always somewhere between those
two uh poles and
and uh you're right it's the final draft
of the movie
and yeah i don't think i don't i don't
think enough people actually understand
the significance
of editing and what that is to movies
but i want to switch into something i
want to switch into something else real
quick
no matter how much time and money you
have to make any movie
you're always going to be up against the
limitations of something
so can you sort of talk about the
limitations you had
on news of the world and the obstacles
you had to overcome
films are always best when there are
limitations
in my experience and that's one of the
things you know if i go to film school
and talk to young
directors that's one of the things you
have to try and get across is that that
boundaries are your friend not your
enemy because
a movie is made in a time and place
in a context within parameters whether
those parameters are
personal or or financial
or ones of time or ones of
of you know physical space whatever it
is
those parameters are where you make your
film
and if you can embrace your parameters
you
you that's where the filmmaking lies
that's where you have to surmount those
challenges
and the film becomes alive because you
do and in this case
what were the parameters what were the
boundaries what were the challenges the
challenges
were that this took place
in a grand mythic hostile environment
and we shot it in that environment and
that meant
that we were months out in the desert of
new mexico
and you know you're going to locations
like the place where the shootout takes
place where you're going
having to rope yourself up the whole
crew for two hours in the morning
and rope yourself on because it's very
dangerous and you're high up and those
huge granite rocks and you know you know
rattlesnakes and all the rest of it
so that was a challenge you've got the
challenge of a
young actress 11 years old
she's a child uh she's got
a huge part she's got to go toe to toe
with tom hanks
and she has to tell the story of her
uh her double orphaning if i can put it
that way
without the luxury of flashbacks she has
to tell it through
not and without the luxury of many words
either she has to tell it through
the power of her empathetic acting
uh so that was a boundary and you know
she transcended that
magnificently you've got always the
pressure of
time and money and the need to lead
your crew and your cast you in this
story you've got the particular
uh demands because it's a road movie in
a sense it's an
odyssey it's a journey part of that form
means that the relationship between
the news reader kid tom hanks and the
little girl
uh johanna helena zingle
takes place as they meet characters
along the way it's not a
movie where you have a cast of
characters who run through the film
you meet a character they fall away
because the journey moves on you meet
another cat they fall away
and each of those characters you have to
shape
those parts
so that they are both specific to that
character
but seen born out of the world or that
of the landscape of the film
and each character only has a limited
amount of
time for you to tell the arc of their
story for you to really believe them so
you know you
meet that uh
young boy cali in the in the buffalo
station you know in
in durand and in the course of that
relationship you have to learn
how you know how his brother was killed
by the town boss
uh how he's lost and vulnerable how he's
lit up by the power of kid's
storytelling and how he ultimately takes
his revenge
how he then moves off with kitten
johanna
and wants to be with them because he's
lonely
but most of all what he wants and needs
as kid realizes is a better future and
he can only find that
on his own and that's a touching and
beautiful
story that takes place over what four or
five scenes
nothing really but you have to feel that
these characters you
you're you're comfortable with them when
they come in the story
and you're comfortable with them leaving
the story in quite short order so that's
a
a technical challenge of the form
and then i think the other issue was
with a film like this you've got a
number of elements that you have to
balance you have to balance
the fact that it's a journey in 1870 so
they're not driving fast cars
it's going to be the journey on a wagon
through a large landscape that's got its
own
pace but you've got to
intersperse that with moments of high
excitement and adventure
and you've also got to pepper it with
jeopardy that feels real and you've got
to
convey a landscape that feels true to
those times that doesn't
[Music]
duck the difficult areas of
what 1870 was all about and ultimately
you've got to convey
uh loss
in a way that's truthful and and
powerful and emotional
and then lastly
optimism and healing that doesn't feel
sentimental but
feels earned and that's to do with
the magnificent acting at the heart of
this the magnificent relationship that
they can
chart that
that excitement that sense of danger
that
jeopardy that developing relationship
that developing
uh you know love that they begin you
know the protection that
that kid feels for this child and the
love that she obviously starts to feel
for him as a
as a father and ultimately for it to pay
off in
in in optimism because the film is about
the healing power of storytelling and
also
that these two ordinary people
they're not famous people nobody knows
who they are
they go on a journey that shows us that
it's
that each individual's decency
and the ability to recognize
where we truly belong in this new
landscape
when we get through all of this whatever
this is today
and was then in 1870
there's more that binds us together than
doesn't that's
that's really where you get to and to
make that feel
believable and earned and emotional and
true and unsentimental but moving
and optimistic that's what that's the
challenge of this movie
well i'll say you did it and uh thank
you for that great answer
and uh again nothing wish you nothing
but the best thank you so much for your
time
thank you